[Music]
the same federal judge of Mexican
heritage that candidate Trump said in
2016 was biased against him just gave
President Trump a huge win on the border
wall US District Court Judge Gonzalo
Curiel ruled that the Trump
administration can proceed with plans to
build a border wall regardless of
environmental objections I also want to
get into today's Supreme Court
immigration ruling with our next guest
Univision and fusion anchor Jorge Ramos
he's the author of a new book I just
started stranger the challenge of a
Latino immigrant in the Trump era
Jorge great to see you how are you
thanks so much for inviting me all right
congrats on the book so what is your
take on the Supreme Court ruling that
came down today first of all the one
that says that the border wall can go
forward without concern about the
environmental objections there was a
lawsuit followed yeah I think the first
studies that President Trump is going to
have to think about again the racist
comments that he made about Josh Gonzalo
Curiel because it's exactly the same
judge that now sided with his government
so that racist when you're the president
from mate was yeah I would I by the way
I wouldn't have I don't I don't like to
comment on judges when you're before the
judge on an issue or when your chief
executive I would I wouldn't necessarily
have done that but what part of that
remark was racist because he said he
didn't think someone of Mexican heritage
could rule on immigration related
matters because of that cisely the
definition of racism when you think that
someone cannot do his job simply because
of his heritage and President Trump
thought that because Josh Gonzalo Curiel
is from Mexican heritage that he
couldn't do his job on on dealing with
from University so that's a racist
statement the same way as it was a
racist statement to say Mexican
immigrants were rapists and at the same
way as it is a racist statement to say
the people from Haiti and African
nations are from [ __ ] countries those
are racist statements made by president
from yeah we know we know that you know
President Obama has used the rocks which
stories we know that others
I've done the same thing I'm thinking
about including different yeah well on
the issue of racism on the issue of
racism particularly you make some really
kind of wild charges in your book that
we're gonna get into in just a moment
but there was another case that came
down on the court today was a 5-3 ruling
that said the US government can
indefinitely detain individuals who are
found at the border who or even green
card holders who they have a reason to
question their legal status that was a
5-3 ruling your reaction to that well
it's not easy to be an immigrant
nowadays in the United States many
people many immigrants feel that they
illegal Jorge you mean illegal immigrant
you always do this and it drives people
nuts no illegals well first of all I
don't call them illegal immigrants
because no one is illegal in in this
world well you've shown in Mexico
they're simply undocumented immigrants
and the fact is that it is increasingly
difficult to be an immigrant in this
country Donald Trump has made this a
hostile dangerous nation for many
immigrants undocumented and document
Latino Latino unemployment is at a
record low it was 4.8% last month that
was the record low now it's a real point
nine percent that's not a good statistic
for you what do you wanted at 2% that
would be nice I'll take that too I think
that's that's positive when it comes to
economics but how about if you're a
family whose father or mother has been
deported how about if you're one of the
people that the from government has
arrested the arrest in the Trump first
year are 30 percent higher than in the
last year of Barack Obama
so okay sure unemployment is right is
better for poor Latinos however Donald
Trump has been arrested many more people
than Barack I'm a real simple I'm a
simple person at the bottom of all that
so my question to you is do you believe
in nationhood absolutely believe in
Nations absolutely and I believe that
every single country has the right to
protect this border I do they have the
right do countries have the
to determine who comes into the country
and who must leave their country do they
have that sovereign right I do believe
that but I also believe Laura that we
are partly responsible for the 11
million undocumented immigrants who are
in this country simply because we
benefit from their work every single day
from the food that we ate to the homes
that they are building to the to the
children that they take care of
undocumented immigrants they pay taxes
they create pay taxes I'm so apparent
that every illegal immigrants the
residents a cat from the tree I mean
there was also a daca recipient just of
last week who was arrested you probably
read it I thought for making threats
against a school so every time we hear
dakka dakka dakka who everyone's
supposed to think oh these are all
future valedictorians maybe some of them
will be that's my point but we have it
we have a right as Abigail Hernandez and
she was arrested she's in Federal
Detention right now up in Yonkers New
York arrested for making a threat
against the school she didn't attend by
the way for every every time you say
that it's bad for immigrants in the
United States why do so many people want
to come to this country if this is a
country that is not welcoming to legal
immigrants people who have the faith in
the system and follow the law not for
those who break the law and then expect
special benefits on the other side so
analyzing hear about how recipients are
you criminalizing to me it would be the
same way as if I say that all
non-hispanic whites are like Steven
paddock the man who killed 58 people in
Vegas possible for what Adam did in in
Sandy Hook it's exactly the same
comparison you cannot criminalize oh
they're already here we don't have to
criminalize them they're here only then
don't so there's a one case all the
dreamers are like that they are not
Jorge in the end this country is the
greatest country in my view I know
you're both the citizen of Mexico you
vote in Mexico
Act I both in Mexico and I vote in the
United States are you gonna vote for
Pena Nieto or now done with them
I think Pena Nieto is one of the worst
presidents that Mexico has ever had and
now one we need you to run that country
I'm part of the United States and I'm
not now you want to stay here but but I
think honestly I think president Pena
Nieto has been one of the worst
presidents that Mexico has had he didn't
have the courage to tell President Trump
in his face that Mexico was not going to
pay for the wall do you think mechs
yeah do you think in the end Mexico will
forge a strong relationship with China
instead of renegotiating NAFTA and
that's gonna be a good thing for Mexico
Communist China I don't know if it's
gonna be a good thing for Mexico I think
a good thing for Mexico would be a
strong relationship with the United
States but if you have the President of
the United States who wants Mexico to
pay for the wall and term husband tell
the truth to everyone Mexico won't pay
for that wall okay some of it directly
and indirectly Jorge where I don't see
that I don't know there might be a new
trade agreement we might have a new a
whole new business arrangement with
Mexico that will be great for Mexico and
good for the United States but I love
having you on thank you so much and
congratulations on your book stranger
thing I love having you on thanks so
much